« L'amour, c'est l'infini mis à la portée
des caniches », écrit Céline dans Voyage
au bout de la nuit. Cette formule moqueuse
signifie que les hommes survalorisent l’amour,
et qu’en cela ils se bercent d’illusions.
Ils en sont même ridicules. Si un chien de
grand-mère est capable d’aimer, c’est
bien qu’il n’y a là nul mystère, nulle
transcendance, nulle élévation de l’âme.
Ce jugement pessimiste nous pousse à réfléchir
à la valeur de l’amour.
Le Dictionnaire de l’Académie française
donne au verbe « aimer » deux sens principaux
: c’est tout d’abord éprouver pour quelqu’un
une inclination tendant à l’union ; mais
ce peut être aussi apprécier une chose.
Le verbe renvoie bien sûr au nom commun « amour
», qu’on peut définir comme un intense
sentiment d’attachement qui rend l’être
humain capable de faire abnégation de son
intérêt individuel.
Le verbe « aimer » frappe l’esprit par
son pouvoir évocateur. Prononcé seul, il
nous fait prendre la mesure de tout ce qu’il
représente. Il nous communique le sentiment
de la transcendance propre au sentiment amoureux.
Le dire ou l’écrire ainsi, c’est donc
conférer à l’acte d’aimer une valeur
très spéciale, unique et précieuse. Or,
cette valeur sacrée relève pour nous de
l’évidence. Qui oserait contredire Serge
Gainsbourg lorsqu’il chante dans La Javanaise
que « La vie ne vaut d'être vécue sans
amour » ? Aimer, pensons-nous, est ce qui
donne tout leur sens à nos existences : il
faut aimer des choses, et surtout il faut
aimer des êtres. Cette idée est le présupposé
majeur de toute notre culture. De ce point
de vue, d’innombrables chansons, films,
romans, pièces de théâtre, poèmes, peintures,
ne sont que des variations sur un seul et
même thème ; des répétitions pour confirmer
notre croyance, pour ancrer notre inébranlable
foi en l’amour. Pourquoi donc aimer serait-il
si essentiel ? Il s’agit de trouver les
fondements de notre certitude. Mais la valeur
sacrée que nous accordons à l’amour est-elle
pour autant naturelle et intangible ? Peut-être
prenons-nous en la matière, comme souvent,
nos préjugés pour des vérités universelles.
Faudra-t-il alors reléguer l’amour au rang
des illusions et renoncer à en tirer un quelconque
sens ?
Aimer est-il forcément ce qui donne du sens
à notre existence ?
Si l’importance de l’amour paraît de
prime abord consubstantielle à la vie même
(I), sa sacralisation serait en réalité
le propre d’une époque et d’une culture
(II), c’est pourquoi il faudrait apprendre
à aimer afin de réaliser la promesse de
sens de l’amour (III).
L’amour est essentiel dans notre existence
parce qu’il servirait la vie même.
Il semble tout d’abord qu’aimer les choses
favorise la survie de l’individu. Le sens
commun dit que l’être humain accorde de
la valeur à une chose parce qu’il en tire
un surcroît de bien-être, mais on peut faire
l’hypothèse que le bien-être accompagne
un bénéfice. Par exemple, nous aimons le
soleil parce que sa lumière a de nombreux
bienfaits pour le corps humain ; ou encore
nous préférons la nourriture très calorique
parce que cette préférence a longtemps favorisé
notre survie, lorsque les ressources étaient
rares et que les animaux nous empêchaient
d’y accéder. La psychologie évolutionniste
affirme que le bien-être associé aux choses
que nous aimons a une « vertu adaptative
». Pour Bentham, la condition humaine se
ramène à une balance des plaisirs et des
peines. « C’est à eux seuls, écrit-il,
qu’il appartient de nous indiquer ce que
nous devons faire comme de déterminer ce
que nous ferons » (Introduction aux principes
de morale et de législation). Les penchants
naturels de l’individu seraient les critères
les plus fiables pour guider son action. Nous
aurions donc intérêt à aimer les choses
que la vie nous dicte d’aimer.
En prolongeant le raisonnement à l’échelle
collective, on arrive à l’idée que l’amour
sexuel favorise la survie de l’espèce.
L’enjeu de la passion amoureuse dépasserait
donc l’individu. Cela expliquerait pourquoi
le désir sexuel apparaît à la fois plus
naturel et plus puissant que toute autre forme
d’aspiration. Seulement, son association
— à géométrie variable — avec le sentiment
amoureux brouille les pistes et rend l’idée
de la ruse de l’espèce déplaisante. Nous
comprenons bien la finalité de la pulsion
sexuelle chez les animaux, mais l’amour
humain, croyons-nous, ne se réduit pas à
cela. Schopenhauer infirme cette croyance.
Il pose que la reproduction est le seul but
véritable de toute passion amoureuse. Derrière
les apparences, derrière tous les discours
sur l’amour, c’est la volonté de l’espèce
qui prévaut. Le philosophe affirme même
que l’individualisation du sentiment amoureux,
c’est-à-dire la sélection précise de
l’aimé, vise l’amélioration de l’humanité.
En découle l’attirance des contraires : « les
hommes de petite taille, par exemple, recherchent
les femmes grandes, les blonds aiment les
brunes, etc. » (Métaphysique de l’amour).
Cette hypothèse amusante est douteuse, mais
elle n’invalide pas l’idée selon laquelle
c’est le destin de l’espèce qui se joue
dans l’amour-passion.
Le même raisonnement permet enfin d’expliquer
l’importance de l’amour du prochain : cette
inclination naturelle favorise la survie du
groupe. Cette idée s’éclaire à la lumière
de l’histoire de l’humanité. Pendant
très longtemps, nous avons vécu en tribus
d’une centaine d’individus maximum. Tous
les membres se connaissaient personnellement
et les relations intimes suffisaient à assurer
la cohésion de la collectivité. La solitude
et l’intimité étaient rares, la promiscuité
et l’interdépendance étaient la règle.
Voici donc pourquoi la compagnie et le souci
d’autrui seraient des penchants innés chez
l’être humain. Richard Dawkins dévoile
le sens biologique de ces penchants : notre
altruisme n’est pas désintéressé, car
à l’origine il protège notre patrimoine
génétique. Dans cette théorie, l’amour
du prochain dérive de la tendance d’un
gène à aider les répliques de lui-même
se trouvant dans d’autres corps. Pourquoi
les parents aiment-ils leurs enfants ? Parce
que leurs gènes ont intérêt à « investir
» dans des individus plus faibles qui pourront
préserver et transmettre leurs répliques.
« L’amour universel et le bien-être des
espèces en général sont des concepts qui
n’ont absolument aucun sens quand on parle
d’évolution », estime l’éthologue dans
Le Gène égoïste. Aimer son prochain serait
donc aussi un avantage évolutif.
Si l’importance de l’amour nous semble
relever de l’évidence, c’est parce qu’elle
serait inscrite dans la vie même. Mais à
y regarder de plus près, la valeur exceptionnelle
que nous voyons dans l’acte d’aimer n’est
peut-être pas aussi naturelle qu’il n’y
paraît.
En consultant l’histoire, nous nous rendons
compte que l’amour n’a pas toujours eu
la place qu’il a aujourd’hui dans nos
vies.
La valorisation de l’amour des choses peut
apparaître comme une conséquence du progrès
de la liberté individuelle. En effet, l’injonction
moderne à « faire ce que l’on aime » n’a
de sens que parce qu’un grand nombre d’options
s’offrent à l’individu. Il est libre
de choisir ce qu’il aime et d’en jouir
: ses affinités, sa sexualité, ses convictions,
sa religion, son métier, son lieu de vie,
et bien sûr, en tant que consommateur, « client
roi », les produits et les services qui lui
plaisent. Puis il est libre de changer d’avis.
En tant que citoyen d’une démocratie, il
exerce sa liberté d’appréciation lorsqu’il
élit ses dirigeants. Dans L’existentialisme
est un humanisme, Sartre met en lumière la
radicalité de cette liberté de l’individu
qui doit s’inventer lui-même, plutôt que
de recevoir son identité des traditions.
En particulier, puisque Dieu n’existe pas,
l’homme ne peut se raccrocher à rien — mais
il est libre. « Condamné à être libre
[...], écrit le philosophe, l’homme n’est
rien d’autre que son projet, [...] il n’est
donc rien d’autre que l’ensemble de ses
actes, rien d’autre que sa vie ». Ainsi,
c’est parce que nous sommes radicalement
libres que choisir, préférer, c’est-à-dire
aimer les choses, devient un acte d’une
valeur fondamentale.
La valorisation de l’amour-passion serait,
elle, une construction culturelle. L’Amour
avec un grand A devient un mythe occidental
entre les XIe et XVe siècles. Avec la fin
des invasions barbares, la vie sociale se
stabilise et se développe, donc les interactions
entre les deux sexes sont plus fréquentes.
Mais surtout, les croisades donnent l’occasion
à de nombreux chevaliers célibataires de
convoiter les femmes, riches et seules, voire
veuves, des seigneurs partis au combat. C’est
« l’amour courtois » : comme la dame est,
de par son statut social, inatteignable pour
le chevalier célibataire, celui-ci fantasme,
survalorise l’objet de son désir, et fait
de sa conquête la grande affaire de son existence.
Denis de Rougemont estime que cette nouvelle
conception de l’amour est d’inspiration
religieuse. Elle plongerait ses sources dans
le catharisme, une secte chrétienne (contemporaine
du roman courtois) pour laquelle la souffrance
est la condition de l’élévation spirituelle.
Alors apparaît dans la culture occidentale
du XIIe siècle, et en particulier dans les
poèmes des troubadours, l'amour-passion,
le fait d'adorer en souffrant un être inaccessible.
« Ce qui exalte le lyrisme occidental, écrit
Rougemont, [...] c'est moins l'amour comblé
que la passion d'amour. Et passion signifie
souffrance » (L’Amour et l’Occident).
La sacralisation de l’amour-passion serait
donc un phénomène culturel occidental.
On peut arriver à la même conclusion en
étudiant la forme d’amour aujourd’hui
supérieure à toutes les autres, l’amour
parental. La théorie de l’évolution explique
certes pourquoi il s’agit d’un attachement
crucial : il en va de la perpétuation de
l’espèce, et plus précisément des gènes
— mais est-ce bien la nature qui nous dicte
de voir en l’enfant un être « sacré » au
sens étymologique, c’est-à-dire digne
de sacrifice ? À la vérité, cette attitude
est historiquement récente : elle commence
à la fin XVIIe siècle en Europe. Alors que
les parents donnaient à l’enfant une valeur
inférieure à celle d’un adulte, ils se
mettent à l’aimer de manière inconditionnelle.
Philippe Ariès lie ce nouveau sentiment au
mariage d’amour. En effet, le consentement
des époux introduit l’affection dans le
mariage, et par là dans la famille. « La
famille commence alors à s’organiser autour
de l’enfant, écrit l’historien, à lui
donner une importance telle qu’il sort de
son ancien anonymat, qu’on ne peut pas sans
grande peine le perdre et le remplacer » (L'Enfant
et la vie familiale sous l'Ancien Régime).
Ainsi, même la valorisation de l’amour
qui nous semble le plus important serait en
réalité le propre d’une époque et d’une
culture.
Aimer paraît certes d’une importance cruciale
pour la vie même, mais le sentiment d’infini
que nous inspire le verbe à lui seul — ce
sentiment puissant, peut-être religieux,
n’exprimerait pas une réalité éternelle.
Les hommes changent, et l’amour change avec
eux. Faut-il pour autant renoncer à chercher
du sens dans l’acte d’aimer ?
Puisque la plénitude que l’homme ordinaire
s’attend à recevoir de l’amour est une
croyance qui a germé dans l’évolution
de la vie sociale, c’est à l’homme en
quête de sens d’apprendre à aimer afin
de réaliser la promesse de l’amour.
Il doit tout d’abord apprendre à aimer
les choses. Qu’est-ce à dire ? À l’évidence,
il ne s’agit pas d’aimer les choses comme
on les aime communément. Il ne s’agit pas
de préférer, comme nous l’a inculqué
l’évolution, ce qui favorise notre survie
; ni de choisir, comme nous le permettent
nos libertés individuelles, les éléments
de notre identité. La morale stoïcienne
offre une solution pour aimer avec plus de
profondeur : l’homme peut retrouver du sens
dans son rapport aux choses en cultivant l’amour
du destin. Épictète conseille dans son Manuel
de « vouloir que les choses arrivent comme
elles arrivent ». Par conséquent, le stoïcien
accompli n’apprécie pas certaines choses
plus que d’autres ; il les estime toutes
aussi bonnes les unes que les autres. En s’accordant
ainsi avec l’ordre de la nature, il s’accorde
avec lui-même et retrouve l’unité de sa
vie spirituelle. Nietzsche reprendra à son
compte cet idéal en définissant la sagesse
la plus haute par ce qu’il nommait l’amor
fati, l’amour du destin, de ce qui est là,
devant nous, ici et maintenant. Ce serait
donc en habitant chaque instant de la vie
qu’on pourrait s’épanouir en aimant.
En second lieu, l’homme en quête de sens
doit apprendre à dépasser l’amour-passion.
Cette forme d’amour ne peut que le décevoir,
car elle est par nature instable : l’amoureux
ne sait pas quand est né son sentiment, ni
quand il finira. Mais le fond du problème,
c’est la logique perverse du désir. Éros
est l’amour qui se nourrit de l’absence.
La flamme de la passion brûle tant que le
manque et les obstacles entretiennent le fantasme
; puis elle s’éteint, paradoxalement, en
présence de l’aimé. Platon en déduit
que la forme d’amour la plus haute, la seule
porteuse de sens, ne procède plus du désir.
C’est pourquoi la beauté du corps ne peut
pas inspirer la transcendance de l’amour.
Le philosophe refuse donc l’idée moderne
selon laquelle le rapprochement des corps
peut servir le rapprochement des cœurs. De
son point de vue, il est impossible de spiritualiser
l’acte sexuel. « Celui qui t'aime est celui
qui aime ton âme », fait-il dire à Socrate
dans l’Alcibiade majeur. L’amour est créateur
de sens si et seulement si il est une passion
absolue, à la fois intellectuelle et religieuse.
Apprendre à aimer, ce serait donc apprendre
à aimer l’essence de l’être aimé.
Mais il faut encore trouver du sens dans l’amour
du prochain. La psychologie évolutionniste
nous dit que cette forme d’attachement n’est
que l’atavisme de notre longue interdépendance
dans la vie tribale, et la biologie de l’évolution
part du principe que notre altruisme est forcément
borné par l’égoïsme de nos gènes. Cela
nous condamne-t-il pour autant à aimer comme
le veut la nature ? Ne pouvons-nous pas là
aussi, comme pour l’amour-passion, imaginer
dépasser nos penchants ordinaires ? Le christianisme
promeut un tel idéal, celui d’un amour
radical, car universel et inconditionnel.
Dans cet idéal, les actions humaines sont
entièrement tournées vers l’amour du prochain.
« Tu aimeras ton prochain comme toi-même
», commande Jésus-Christ dans l’Évangile
selon Matthieu. Il faut aimer son semblable
quel qu’il soit, et lui faire du bien sans
rien attendre en retour. Cet effort sera encore
plus porteur de sens s’il vise ceux qui
ne le méritent pas : « aimez vos ennemis
et faites du bien à ceux qui vous haïssent,
bénissez ceux qui vous maudissent, priez
pour ceux qui vous diffament », précise
le Christ dans l’Évangile selon Saint-Luc.
Le verbe « aimer » évoque pour nous, à
lui seul, toute la profondeur de l’amour.
Nous ressentons, en le lisant ou en l’entendant,
qu’il exprime ce qu’il y a d’essentiel
dans nos existences. De fait, l’importance
de l’amour serait consubstantielle à la
vie même. Aimer, c’est tout d’abord survivre
: l’individu aime les choses que lui a dictées,
le long de l’évolution, la pression de
l’environnement ; la femme aime l’homme,
et réciproquement, parce qu’il en va de
la perpétuation de l’espèce ; les membres
d’un groupe s’aiment parce qu’ils sont
interdépendants. Cette analyse n’explique
cependant pas pourquoi nous pensons aujourd’hui
qu’aimer est pourvoyeur de sens. Et en effet,
cette idée est récente à l’échelle de
l’histoire de l’humanité. En Occident,
aimer est sacré depuis que nous sommes plus
libres de vivre comme nous l’entendons ; depuis
que l’idéal de l’amour courtois s’est
diffusé dans toute la société ; et depuis
que la famille est devenue un lieu d’affection.
La promesse de sens du verbe « aimer » n’est-elle
donc qu’une illusion propre à notre culture
moderne ? Peut-être faut-il en réalité,
pour réaliser cette promesse, apprendre à
aimer. Apprendre à aimer le destin ; apprendre
à aimer l’âme plutôt que le corps ; et
apprendre à aimer radicalement tous les hommes.
Certes, ce n’est pas facile. Surtout pour
les caniches.
Avant de vous laisser, j’ai une question
pour vous : et si vous pouviez jeter votre
cours sur le thème à la poubelle ?
Et si vous pouviez réussir les dissertations
de culture générale des concours, mais aussi
les DS de votre prépa… avec seulement 10
pages ?!
Depuis que j’ai popularisé ma méthode
des paragraphes en 2016, les élèves qui
l’adoptent gagnent rapidement des points.
Tout en gagnant beaucoup de temps !
Ça vous intéresse ?
Je vous révèle les 5 étapes de ma méthode
dans la vidéo qui apparaît maintenant à
l’écran.
Vous pouvez également la trouver en écrivant
« Prépa HEC méthode des paragraphes » dans
la barre de recherche de YouTube.
Regardez-la attentivement jusqu’au bout,
et vous saurez exactement comment gagner facilement
des points en dissertation de culture générale
cette année... tout en gagnant beaucoup de
temps.